my motivation for doing this series of
three or four videos on the fractional
on the fractional reserve banking system
isn't because I expect some type of
revolutionary change or I think that the
world is going to end if we don't if we
keep fractional reserve banking the
whole reason why I want to do it is just
to kind of clarify our collective
thoughts on what it is and what are its
weaknesses I mean it is the system that
we're in and by the way that it's often
talked about it's kind of viewed as the
only system because it's kind of you
know banks around the world now use the
system but we have to realize that this
is a system a structure that's been in a
place in its modern form for on the
order of a hundred years and it isn't
the only way to do banking and this has
some very obvious flaws that I've gone
over in the last couple of videos and
just to kind of highlight them the first
one and this is one that would strike
anyone is at least it would make them
uncomfortable is just this disingenuous
nature of fractional reserve practice
ingenuously tell someone you can get
your deposits anytime you want but the
reality is you can get your deposits
anytime you want as long as no more than
10% of people want their money at that
same time and obviously that by itself
might make a little uncomfortable but
that by itself isn't a whole reason to
to say that a system is bad but the more
severe problem is is that this kind of
half lie leads to the notion of a bank
run everyone has the right to get all of
their money back on essentially on a
day's notice or on an hours notice but
the reality is that everyone can't get
all of their money back on an hours
notice so that leads to an inconsistency
and some people aren't going to get what
they expected and this leads to a panic
this leads to a generalized
panic and which is of course a very
unstable situation for your entire
financial system you don't want an
unstable financial system unstable
financial system financial system so to
fix this problem of bank runs and panics
there have been kind of two fixes here
you have your lender of last resort
lender of last resort in the Federal
Reserve of last resort and then probably
more importantly
you have the notion of FDIC insurance
FDIC insurance and in the last video I
talked about the idea that FDIC
insurance the main negative I see it it
essentially gives all banks the same
access to capital because they all say
hey look give me your money and it's
insured so essentially it's a federal
subsidy federal subsidy for all banks
for all banks I mean by definition the
fact that the FDIC is about to be
insolvent will have to go back to
Congress to ask for more money that
means that it was under charging for the
insurance so it was subsidizing these
banks and since all of these banks have
the same FDIC insurance and they're
paying a slight different amount for
them what it leads to is encourages
risk-taking it encourages risk-taking
risk-taking to essentially get more
profits more profits because all of the
bank's borrowing costs are the same
because when they take on more risk
people don't say hey you're a riskier
Bank I need more money from you to give
me your deposit they say hey no I might
be a reformer secure bank but I'm FDIC
insured just like that more conservative
Bank down the street so I should be able
to I'll just pay the slightly higher
deposit just for giving me your business
but then I can go take big risks and
it's essentially subsidized by the
federal government but even here you
might say hey look we've been you know
the u.s. runs on a fractional reserve
banking system and it's clearly kind of
the financial or the economic powerhouse
of the world and those are both true and
obviously other modern countries are all
based on on fractional reserve banking
so what's wrong with it maybe we have
these weaknesses but we've engineered
away the problem and the main I guess
the best way to answer that question and
I really don't want to you know I guess
I want to make it very clear that when I
started off thinking about this problem
because I've gotten a lot of requests
for people to think about the problem I
came of it I came at it as as from as
neutral a position as possible you know
I said you know I don't want to just say
it's bad and be kind of this reactionary
radical person but the more you think
about it the more that you realize that
it there is something that just doesn't
fit right here
when you talk about any financial
intermediary what's its purpose let me
draw a financial intermediary right here
financial intermediary you have savers
you have savers who like to put their
money in a nice big vault some place or
maybe they would like it invested
someplace but they just don't know how
to invest it or they don't have their
money doesn't have to have the scale so
it can be invested properly and what the
financial intermediary says hey savers
give me all of your money and I'll hire
some really smart people to invest your
money properly in good investments so
you have your savers on this side and
then you have your projects or your
investments on this side you have your
investments they're essentially they
might loan out the money as if it's you
know I'm speaking very general terms and
we're talking about a commercial bank or
lending out the money if you're talking
about a venture capital fund they're
making direct investments in actual
startup companies but the idea for any
financial intermediary is the same for
them to create value they're taking the
savers money and they're putting it
investments that should generate some
positive yield so it'll generate some
positive return if they invested right
so some positive return and they'll give
some fraction of that return back to the
savers so they'll give some fraction of
that return back to the savers and
they'll keep some of them for themselves
which is you know you might say is
reasonable if they're doing this work
and they're allocating this capital
they're providing a useful function for
society so this right here is a useful
function for society and these people
deserve to be wearing their Armani suits
and and have their rowlock Rolex watches
output deserve and quotation marks but
you can say they are adding value to our
economy now what it will does is is
fractional reserve banking a requirement
to have financial intermediaries like
this and the simple answer is no you
don't need fractional reserve banking to
do this in fact many financial
intermediaries and in no way participate
in the fractional reserve lending system
I guess the most obvious one is venture
capitalists regardless of what you think
of them capitalists
they are not there's not some kind of
they tell there they tell their
investors which are the equivalent of
the depositors for a bank they tell them
look you're going to have your money
locked up you're going to have your
money locked up for you know X years or
they'll say look we'll take your money
as we need it once we take your money is
going to be locked up that's also
through private equity funds
some people consider a venture
capitalist subset of private equity but
private equity more invest in companies
that already exist they do that and
hedge funds maybe they don't have a
lock-up hedge funds for the most part
some of them might actually tell you
look we're going to lock your money up
so they're being very up front with
their investors you know and I don't
want to defend them but you know on the
ones that don't have a lock-up they'll
invest in liquid instruments they invest
in liquid instruments and I don't you
know hedge funds this is a big group of
people some of them are adding some
value to society some of them aren't
probably the great majority of them are
just trading funds between each other in
some type of a game but I won't go into
that debate I won't try to defend all of
the hedge fund world but that the notion
is you this to be a financial
intermediary you do you're not dependent
on fractional reserve banking even if
you had a even if you wanted to run a
commercial bank I could take deposits so
let's say you come to me let's say a
bunch of people come to me let's say
this is your deposit right here this is
your money let's say you have $100 right
here this right here is $100 I could
tell you look if you give if you want
money on demand I'm not going to I'm not
going to pay you any interest on that
for the service of you having access to
it on your ATM and for it to be secured
and all of that I'm actually going to
maybe charge you a little bit of money
for on-demand money and everything and
if you want interest on your money you
have to give me your money for a certain
period of time so what you do is so
you've given me your $100 you've given
me your $100 just like that and you say
you know what I would like to get some
interest on my money I I'm a
sophisticated investor I'd like to
participate in the miracles of
capitalism so let me tell you what I
only need out of this hundred dollars
I'm
ten dollars on a daily basis to run my
business or my household so I'm going to
make this a demand account so that would
be just a checking account and for that
I'll get no interest no interest I might
even have to pay some money now the
other part the more the longer I'm
willing to lock up my money for I'm
going to I'm going to give the more that
you're willing to lock up your money for
I'm going to give you more interest in
so let's say that you other so this is
ten dollars right here let's say well I
might need some of my money in a year so
let me put the rest of it in for one
year so we'll call that one year CD
which exists already the one year CD and
for this the bank will pay you two
percent or you know maybe maybe three
percent and then you said you know the
rest of the money this is long-term
retirement money and I'll put it in a
ten year CD ten your CD and because I've
locked it up longer I'm going to get
more interest maybe I'll get five
percent for that and now me the
commercial bank that's not participating
in fractional reserve banking can say
look this guy has this ten dollars that
he wants access to whenever and I'm not
paying any interest on that I'm just
allowing him to use my financial
infrastructure so I'm just going to put
that aside I'm just going to put it in
my vaults and he can access that from
his ATM or wherever but this money out
here I can then lend this out so if
someone comes to me and say hey Sal or
Sal bank I have this project and I want
to be able to blend borrow you know
let's say that this right here is let's
say this is right here is $45 I need to
borrow $45 for eight years they say sure
you know I don't have to give this guy
his money back until ten years from now
so what you do is you take that $45 and
you loaned it out which is fine because
you know it's going to be back as long
as you're loaning it out properly it
should be back in time to pay this guy
and this guy knows that you're loaning
out this money so he knows that there's
some risk inherent this and he should do
his homework before he buys this
ten-year CD from you
he should see where you're loaning your
money and how risky it is and if it's
not if it's really risky he should want
more than 5% you should focus on the
interest rate or he should just not give
you his money so the the natural supply
and demand and
kind of the natural forces feedback
forces of capitalism would come into
play so you can completely run a
financial system with banks and and and
all sorts of financial intermediaries
without fractional reserve banking so
now the next question is ok you can do
it without fractional reserve banking
but what is the real what is the real
what what's really wrong about what
fractional reserve banking is enabling
and for that I'll have to review the
yield curve for you so the yield curve
it's nothing fancy it's really just a
graph showing what people are how much
interest you pay for different durations
or how much interest you get so let's
say this is the yield curve let's say
right here I have overnight money so
let's say this is if you give a loan for
one day this is if you give a loan for
one year and this is say this give you
give a loan for 10 years and there could
be all sorts of a duration is just how
long you're giving the loan out for now
if you're lending money to the
government which you view as as safe
maybe it may be the safest person to
lend money to then you can say look the
government for one day I'm willing to
lend money to them for one percent for
one year I'm you know I'm locking it up
maybe it's 2 percent and then for 10
years I'm willing to lend it to them for
5 percent so this is the yield curve
will look something like this actually
let me just draw it like this the yield
curve tends to look something like that
doesn't always go upward sloping like
that but it tends to go upward sloping
like that so that's the yield curve and
this might be for this might be for
Treasuries
that's for Treasuries right there so one
day to one percent one year maybe the
way I drew it maybe this is like three
percent made for 10 years this would be
like 5 percent this isn't the current
yield curve but you get the idea and
this would just be for Treasuries to
risk it the the safest borrower now for
investment grade companies if I'm trying
to lend money to them maybe to a GE or
someone like that our Berkshire Hathaway
I'd want some premium over the
Treasuries because they're not as safe
as the US government but it's going to
have a curve similar to that maybe it
looks like that alright and this premium
right here is essentially the amount of
more interest you would want from these
still relatively safe companies relative
to Treasuries but you
this upward-sloping as you go up and
then finally you might have your really
risky guys and every company will have
its own yield curve based on its
borrowing cost but you might group a
bunch of risky guys together and you say
look the risky guys the yield curve
looks like this that you know if there's
some guy who's looking to start some new
biotech firm and he wants to borrow
money from him I'm gonna charge a much
higher premium over Treasuries because I
don't even know if he's going to be
around in let's say this is you know in
five years so because this is just the
yield curve and the whole reason why I
drew this is to show how fractional
reserve banking allows banks to
essentially take advantage of the yield
curve without really adding any true
value to society this notion of a
financial intermediary does add value to
society when you have fractional reserve
banking what you're allowing banks to do
is to take deposits and this you know
fractional reserve banking isn't the
only place where this happens this
happens a lot of places but they take
deposits and their demand deposits right
these are checking deposits which are
essentially loans from their depositors
and they are essentially overnight loans
right these are on-demand loans on
demand loans they're essentially when
you give your money to a bank in a
checking deposit that's essentially
every hour that you don't go and take
your money back they are essentially
just renewing that loan it's a
continuous on this kind of the shortest
possible duration loan and every day you
don't do it is just kind of a renewal of
that loan right you could imagine a
world where every year you Rin you alone
every year that you don't withdraw it
you just keep pulling it over when you
do on demand it's every second that you
don't withdraw it you're renewing it so
they're able to borrow money at this
part of the yield curve and they can do
it very safely pay very little interest
because people they even though they
might be doing risky activities maybe
they're lending to people like this guy
because of the FDIC insurance people are
lending to them like they're the
government because they're going to get
paid back if the government can be paid
them back so it really lowers their
borrowing cost so they borrow down here
and what it does is it allows them it
allows them to lend money to lend money
over longer durations so this could be a
10 year loan so the money doesn't get
paid back only interest does in the
interim but the money doesn't get paid
back for 10 years
maybe this right here is a 5 year loan
and they can do it two more two riskier
investments I mean one they could just
they could just borrow money here which
is what they're paying the depositors
like 1% and then they could just invest
it if they want to do it if the yield
curve look like this they could invest
it in Treasuries or maybe investment
grade bonds essentially lending to you
know the Berkshire Hathaway's of the
world and getting a lot more interest
but getting a lot more interest and what
they did here it doesn't take any
special genius to do this everyone knows
that you'll get higher interest here
then over here but the only reason why
they can do it this way is because they
have this implicit guarantee actually
it's an explicit guarantee from the FDIC
from the FDIC so this FDIC insurance is
what allows people to lend the money
people are only willing to part with
their money at this point of the yield
curve because of the FDIC insurance and
then the bank can then go and invest at
this point of the yield curve and then
make the difference on the spread
they'll get 5% on the money and then
only pay 1% and where is the value here
because I could do this but I don't I'm
not an FDIC insured entity you know
clearly these people would love to get
5% on their money get that money that
the bank's getting but they don't get
that insurance from the FDIC so it
doesn't allow them to so essentially
what fractional reserve banking and the
insurance that's come about to make
fractional reserve lending viable it's
really all it does is it allows banks to
arbitrage the yield curve to borrow
money at the short end and lend it out
at the long end and make and make up the
spread and this is kind of a you know
one that doesn't add any value anyone
can do this you don't need a fancy MVA
to figure this out this doesn't add any
true value to the site it actually just
flattens out the yield curve a little
bit but that you know we can debate
about the value of that but I want to
kind of make a bigger point here is that
obviously a lot of people in the banking
system are kind of the champions of
capitalism I'll even write it down here
champions champions of capitalism you
know and they they unless they're being
bailed out they're the first ones to be
against any form of government
and intervention or government safety
net but their whole industry the whole
industry is predicated on a government
safety net this notion of a financial
intermediary that I outlined here with
venture capitalists and private equity
and they they still operate on this
model right here they are in no way
dependent on the federal government I
mean some of them might end up being
indirectly but they don't need a whole
elaborate system of FDIC insurance and
the federal and the discount window and
all of these interventions that the
federal government does they don't need
that to operate efficiently and you can
even or to operate in general and then
even this banking system here where you
just had people get CDs instead of
having this kind of halfway truth of
fractional reserve vending this could
completely operate without any
government intervention this system on
the other hand fractional reserve
lending it could not exist without
government intervention it could not
exist without government intervention
and so you have to you have to debate or
I guess you know think in your mind some
system like fractional reserve lending
or banking that is dependent is
dependent on the government
is this even capitalism is this even
capitalism I mean where is the
competition here where is the innovation
here if you're big enough you get your
FDIC insurance and you just keep
arbitrage in the yield curve and you
make money to buy your Rolex and and
your you know your fancy trips and your
private jets but there's no innovation
here you're just big and you were one of
the lucky ones to get a bank charter
with the FDIC and and be insured by
there's no innovation here and where's
the competition if anything the person
who takes the most risk and who does the
most silly things is going to be able to
generate the highest yield and they have
the subsidized insurance from the
federal government and so they're going
to be the most successful it's all
dependent on government it's all
dependent on a subsidy and in the end
this money that these people are making
this money that they're making by
arbitrage in this this is coming from a
subsidy from the federal government is
coming from the taxpayer so you
essentially have the taxpayers
subsidizing this world where people can
just arbitrage this yield curve not take
on real risk and make real investments
and if
ashlee allocate capital just arbitrary
just arbitrage in the yield curve with
cheap insurance and you're essentially
making a small percentage of the of the
population being able to extract
essentially rents or or some type of
subsidy from the rest of the population
and obviously this isn't the part of our
of our economic system that is the most
in need so I'm not saying this to kind
of impune the financial system I think
for the most part people here they're
taking on risk and they're getting
returned and you know the savers here
know what they're getting into but
there's no government intervention here
there's no implicit government subsidy
this whole thing is based on a
government subsidy fractional reserve
banking could not exist without the FDIC
and the FDIC could not exist without the
implicit bank backing of the that the
Congress would make them solvent if they
ever ran out of money like is the case
right now anyway hopefully this informs
your view a little bit more I don't want
to be some kind of you know a crazy
reactionary I've kind of resigned to the
fact I'm resigned to the fact that you
know fractional reserve banking isn't
going to go away but it does bother me a
little bit because it is it is
completely dependent on government
intervention as you see right now over
the past year you have this whole
financial system where where we're
piling more and more money into the very
same entities that took on the most risk
and essentially they have us they're you
know they have a set gun point they're
like you better pour more money into us
or else we're going to blow up because
of the risks I took but I'm going to
take you down with me